Więc koncepcja fundamentalizmu jest zasadniczo powiązana z
pojęciem pomiaru w mechanice kwantowej
zanim mechanika kwantowa została opracowana
naukowcy powszechnie wiedzieli, że jeśli masz układ w danym
stanie, to ten
stan jest określony
i jeśli wykonasz na nim pomiar, to dostaniesz
bardzo dobrze określony wynik
w mechanice kwantowej tak już nie jest — możesz mieć
układ będący w doskonale zdefiniowanym stanie
i mimo to, gdy wykonujesz pewne
pomiary, możesz dostawać losowe wyniki
żeby lepiej zobrazować tę koncepcję, muszę
wprowadzić pojęcie superpozycji
superpozycja to koncepcja, która nie jest tu niczym nowym
opiera się na tym, że układ wyświetla
kilka liniowych kombinacji stanów jednocześnie
i możesz o tym myśleć
na przykład jak o fali radiowej niosącej
wiele różnych częstotliwości — nie ma w tym
nic niezwykłego z ludzkiego punktu widzenia
to, co nadaje superpozycji kwantowy smak, to fakt
pomiaru układu
zilustruję to przykładem
wyobraź sobie, że masz układ strzałek
i przygotowujesz ten układ
tak, żeby wszystkie strzałki wskazywały w lewo
a potem podchodzisz i
zadajesz pytanie: czy jesteś w górze czy w dole?
i ponieważ strzałki wskazują w lewo, co można
wyrazić i opisać
jako liniową kombinację między
górą a dołem, dostaniesz
wyniki: pięćdziesiąt procent w górę
i pięćdziesiąt procent w dół, gdy zapytasz czy jest w górze
taki wynik dostajesz z tego układu
a potem możesz przygotować inny stan układu, gdzie połowa
strzałek wskazuje w górę, a połowa
wskazuje w dół, i zadasz to samo pytanie
i dostaniesz ten sam wynik
to są dwa zupełnie różne układy
i utraciłeś tę informację
przynajmniej na razie
jak możesz ustalić, jaka jest różnica?
otóż te układy są bardzo różne
bo w pierwszym przypadku przygotowałeś układ
w czystym stanie i możesz zadać
układowi pytanie, które da ci deterministyczną
nie losową odpowiedź, i tym pytaniem jest: czy jesteś w lewo czy w prawo?
to powie ci ze stuprocentową pewnością: w lewo
w drugim przypadku nie ma pytania, które możesz
zadać i które da ci stuprocentową pewność, bo to jest mieszanina
więc jeśli zapytasz o lewo lub prawo
będzie losowo, bo połowa jest w górze
a połowa w dole; jeśli zapytasz o górę lub dół
też będzie losowo, bo połowa jest w górze
to samo — będzie pięćdziesiąt procent
jak ma się to do losowości w mechanice kwantowej?
możesz sobie wyobrazić, że to jest podobne
do rzutu monetą — wyjdzie orzeł albo reszka
ale to nie jest jak rzut monetą w ogóle
bo gdy rzucasz monetą
jedyny powód, dla którego nie znasz wyniku, który dostaniesz
jest to, że nie znasz
energii, z jaką rzuciłeś monetą, kąta obrotu,
warunków otoczenia w pokoju
i tak dalej; gdybyś znał wszystkie te
zmienne, mógłbyś przewidzieć wynik — orzeł czy reszka
to są zmienne ukryte przed obserwatorem
i przez wiele lat naukowcy sądzili, że istnieją
podobne zmienne w mechanice kwantowej, które
ujawniają się jako losowość
i dopiero wtedy
przełomowa praca Johna Bella z lat sześćdziesiątych faktycznie
wykazała, że tak nie jest
i teraz każdy fizyk
potwierdza, że nie istnieje żadna
teoria ukrytych zmiennych, która byłaby zgodna z mechaniką kwantową
a więc naprawdę jest tak, że gdy mierzysz układ
natura ujawnia wynik losowo
nieważne, jak długo o tym myślę — wciąż
uważam to za niesamowite